oh god it's bad all right go on what you
see about the farm bro
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we closed out season eight with
Scarlett Johansson of course you can
catch her as Black Widow and Avengers
endgame which is set to theaters on
April 26th Scarlett Johansson welcome to
the show thank you very much I know that
you're a chicken wing connoisseur I do
love the chicken wing you've travelled
the world trying them do you like them
spicy they're on my rider I think
there's chicken wings and like Lacroix
and that's basically it
what up look away there you go although
I will say that hot wings and carbonated
beverages that's a bad combo
[Music]
okay so all right now you're just go
you're just going for it just dive in
[Music]
pretty good reason mild yeah not bad
mm-hmm so these Avengers movies they're
really unprecedented in that there's
these three hundred million plus dollar
budgets dozens of a listers in the cast
but then you're shooting places like the
rural Scottish Highlands are these small
towns in southwest Ohio but he did it
past the time like do you hit up local
karaoke joints of the wing spots or
anything like that
well I'm Atlanta certainly try to hit up
as many wing spot that's supposed to do
it oh yeah for sure
God definitely gotta hit up Tmax every
time I'm Atlanta I'm in Atlanta when we
were in Scotland obviously we're in
Edinburgh there's like tons of things to
do and move on to a lot of local bars
and you know people got kind of crazy
couldn't find any wings though what's
that all about I don't know the food in
Scotland's a little that's not true I
don't know like are you doing about like
um what does it have yes yeah I've had
vegan haggis before which was foul
enough I'm like I don't know when you
like actually put innards into the mix
like that could not possibly get yeah I
don't think you need to go too deep into
that world it's a little sweet yep let's
go okay but not too bad mm-hmm so when
you were cast to play princess Mindy in
the spongebob squarepants movie one
thing that director Stephen Hillenburg
boasted about was your love of cartoons
what was a bigger on-set trailer guilty
pleasure for you runnin Stimpy or the
Jerry Springer Show um oh gosh I feel
like those two are just like a perfect
marriage you know they're like sort of
in actually of each other well yeah um
I'd say Jerry Springer I don't feel
guilty about watching Ren and Stimpy but
Jerry Springer you just you just do yeah
do you think that shows like Jerry
Springer is staged or legit like I feel
like an actress of your caliber would be
able to see a phony performance like
it's fine I feel like it's pretty real
Yeah right I think so too because like
people always say it's phony it's phony
but then I'm like well how does that guy
with prison tats like act so well yeah
like that guy deserves like defin
Leigha SAG Award I would say maybe not
an Oscar but like pretty good yeah I
feel like even if the story is like a
little bit off something's rotten in the
state of Denmark you know and I mean if
something's a little rotten how you
feeling I'm good you're good yeah I'd
say it's like Christmas in my mouth it's
a little like it's like explosive cheer
in there yeah yeah for better or worse
oh god the relatives are fighting right
now what's this one this is the patios
potion there's just no glamorous way to
eat them mm-hmm I'm gonna scare it huh
yeah weird it's a weird one mm-hmm so
from your vegan banana chocolate chip
muffins your frittata recipe the chef
Scarlett mythology it's bigger than just
the kitchen which movie set had better
food chef or he's just not that into you
because I think most people would think
the former but I've read that Drew
Barrymore had that like Charlie party
all the time yeah that was awesome
well I had like Rory try cooking for me
on chef like that was basically the best
plate of pasta that ever lived I don't
ever had in my life and then like
Favreau did it and he did a pretty good
job too and I was like oh I'm just here
like an actor eating carbs up for my job
like this is really working for me drew
prides herself on providing the most
sick catering like full chocolate
fountain like raw bar it was like they
were definitely bringing it flower films
they know how to feed people well
speaking of eating carbs for work are
you ready to move on Scarlett um yeah
I'm good okay
[Music]
you know what's remarkable I have a I
have a compliment for your production
team here we might those you need them
desperately
it's amazing how our wings are like the
same looking wing on either so how did
they like no two wings are alike
obviously but like man they really came
close Dom she recognizes the small big
things good job down good job
alright I'm procrastinating clearly are
you a flats kind of guy or mall
drumstick person all things being equal
I'd rather have a drumstick because I
feel you know like I'm a giant or
something oh yeah all things being equal
are you a turkey leg person at Disney or
definitely ramped in the tinfoil and
stuff what about you yeah I like it
they're good yeah I mean it's just so
indulgent and so that's that's that's
okay mm-hmm so in addition to your
decades-long film resume you've also
taken your talents to the stage even
winning a Tony in 2010 for your revival
of a view from the bridge and I heard
James Corden make an interesting point
one time about Hollywood actors who have
stage performance and their no-nonsense
approach because there's no way to be a
diva if you have to do costume changes
in a corridor backstage does that
resonate with you like do you think you
can see each other in the wild you know
when I meet actors especially that come
from like the Royal Academy of Dramatic
Arts in London they'd certainly have a
method to me that's more of like a
flavour I would say that I can recognize
which is the tougher crowd to please
comic book obsessives or Theor buffs
that's an interesting question I guess
probably comic-book obsessives maybe
because it's material that they have
loved from childhood and so they have
the certain kind of ownership over these
characters or the storylines and you
know how it is when you love something
from being a kid and then it can't you
know it's not the way that you imagined
it to be
like it doesn't mean you can't grow to
love it but it's you know you have
feelings about it so this sound is just
so awful he's so sorry
I'm like sucking it through indeed um I
don't think I can taste the difference
between any of these open spaces right
now it's just all like toasty in there I
feel like you put the carriage before
the horse on your description every time
right now I'm just tasting like spite oh
it's got kick there's a little sweet too
so typically on our winged 5 we do a
segment called explain that Graham where
we do a deep dive and I guess Instagram
which would obviously be silly for you
because you don't have an Instagram or
any social media whatsoever in fact you
once told Arianna Huffington I can't
think of anything I'd rather do less
than have to continuously share details
of my everyday life
are you peripherally aware of what's
going on on the internet or do you think
maybe you've put up a wall that
separates you completely from the world
of memes in YouTube um I exist online
sometimes I guess who I start to like
I'm hung feels like kind of thick yeah
memes and stuff like that probably takes
longer to get to me sometimes the
Avengers will like clue me in on stuff
though - yeah I've ever heard of the
avengers inspired infinity war is the
most ambitious crossover event in
history meme have you ever heard of that
no but I want them interested what is on
a crash course yeah oh it's a response
to that Marvel statement right so
infinity war is the most ambitious
crossover event in history and then you
have the internet making counter points
to that okay so I want to show you a few
examples and I'm just curious right now
I'm gonna be like a babe in the woods
cuz like I don't even know what you're
about to show me right now
I'm so like not I'm gonna be your meme
shaman okay okay alright so here's an
example Marvel might say infinity war is
the most ambitious crossover event in
history and then somebody on the
internet right would say me Space Jam
yeah like a counter - oh yeah I got it -
in theme actually that's a good point
I mean space Jones like that was
basically everything also remember like
it was a Who Framed Roger Rabbit
remember that yeah classic that's a
great like it was hugely like that just
opened the world like toon land and they
were all there yeah
so take that space fans how about this
Isis these jams like it's a lot of them
um you know is it like a pocket thing
that there's a feeling inside I think
that they're just crossing over a
breakfast pastry and then some chef boy
or do you I do love Chef Boyardee though
that was my jam a Space Jam is that how
about this this is Henry the Eighth
Francis the first I think this is like
the anglo-french treaty of 1514 too
nerdy for a meme or what do you think
sure if it works for uh Mark Morissette
Longshanks 13:07 it works for you it
works for me and then one more for you I
know that your big Busta fan is on stage
with Mariah Carey but of a crossover
though like that to me is like a perfect
marriage it's not like the pop-tarts and
like Chef Boyardee reference like this I
believe in you know what I mean I'm not
sure all right
thus concludes the crash course is that
a meme this or does it mean move no
that's it what's that that's it this is
awesome it means do memes mood
sorry
[Music]
okay so this is the adobo loco Clos hey
kiddo you know about ghost pepper okay
oh god I'm gonna try to part in an area
that doesn't have a lot
that one's hot run the back half here
scarlet it's getting real so in March
2017 you hosted said night live from the
fifth time I actually am NOT back yet
I think a piece game line I think
forever enshrining you in the show's
prestigious five timer Club
that's right do you still have that
commemorative jacket that Kenan gave you
I know cuz I guess NBC Universal is
really cheap I'll give that back as like
what why are they tearing it away from
me look oh it's part of your costume
change but then I never saw it again
damn that's spicy whoa I need like a cup
to catch my drool ah there's a former I
don't want to do the bomb line you and
everybody else writing it what's in here
it has sodium benzoate in it I feel like
that's bad isn't it no no we have one
more we have one more before we get
there all right let's just eat the next
one before you ask me because I don't
know what just let's just dive in let's
just dive it's that one that one looks
hi
[Music]
I'm scared I'm with ya I want tasty Oh
what's gonna happen
maybe you're just on top of it I'm I oh
my god that's really hot oh yeah gotta
hit that water yeah
I need a beer that's what I need a giant
cold beer somebody go for a run somebody
go on a run for Scarlett oh you were
described in a 2006 Esquire profile as a
card playing magic loving smartass can
you sit back and then just enjoy a magic
show be wowed by it or do you find
yourself obsessing thinking about how
they do the trick
um no I love magic
I love the Magic Castle my voice is
changing
I love the spectacle the fantasy I love
it all I'm not the person that will sit
there and try to look for the strings
attached or you know any of that stuff I
totally like believe in it for the ride
you'll go along for the ride well here
before we get to the bomb I'd like to
show you see this is just a normal
hankers make it disappear make the wing
disappear listen I don't know how to
make the wings disappear I don't know
how to make the spice disappear do it
but I'm gonna send this to me to a realm
and we'll never come back all right
hocus-pocus Alakazam
where'd it go there it is
[Music]
look at the bottle it's just like who
buys up just us I think that looks like
it has an ear oh my god there's one
flake there's a flake I'm flaking off
the flaky part
[Music]
you ate it already burning my nose
[Music]
I want o wallow it's happening
oh no oh it's bad yeah oh it's so bad
it's really bad you're telling me you
told me so starting to film like
Avengers you end up doing press all over
the globe how if at all is entertainment
news different overseas than here I
can't get higher than that
ah we've reached a ceiling I think we're
at maximum levels mm-hmm to borrow a
phrase from my friend Joe gee it burns
mm-hmm oh my god I don't know if I can
recover huh you're gonna you know this
is as bad as it's gonna be this is as
bad it's gonna get and it'll have a
half-life you'll get back you'll get
back oh my head
I got you we're in this together okay
okay uh-huh
oh my I got you it's so hot are you
experiencing this - I am I just know
what to expect I've been here before
believe it or not we've been doing this
show for like eight seasons a hundred
and fifty plus episode my god this has
been around its route here about a
hundred I walk take a lap scarlet I've
had plenty of laps plenty of laps
what now is there anything else to eat
it's a bread do we have some lifelines
do we have some lifelines what is there
Tom's cooking something up what is it
always looking out oh okay what is it we
have some bread we have some rice it's
bad all right go on what do you say
about the for us so you know when you do
a film like Avengers you have to do
press all over the world how if at all
is entertainment news different overseas
countries have different approaches to
stuff
I remember Sam Jackson and I we did this
movie called the spirit together and it
who we were in Germany we did like this
like a European tour it comes back but
it's now in song round 2
um oh god I don't know without that's
gonna make it better or worse what do
you think well you know we're trying
some stuff out here you know we have
bread we have some rice like you know
how much worse can it get you might as
well just take a shot at some things
beer come on okay
Oh at least like after a couple of these
I'll be feeling no pain I felt later
when we were in Germany the press was
just really really like serious did I
think it was just like the state of mind
like maybe we oh my god it's bad are we
going up we are if you can what do I
have to look forward to here like [ __ ]
the question you just asked me was it
that's fair all I can think about is
like what is that just surviving the
show listen I understand that completely
stop being flowery just tell me what the
[ __ ] to expect what's the next thing
tell me here's what I think I think that
if you can handle this hot sauce there's
no hot sauce in the world that can stop
you Scarlett Johansson is that true
that's true
I'm gonna cry yeah and it's not just the
sauce
god this beer is God I drink it so fast
you didn't slam that beer got another
one on deck think Dom might I think you
know I think Dom might have tapped a keg
oh okay okay
[Music]
I'm gonna take a tiny bite yeah
mm-hmm it qualifies like at this point I
may also be chewing my tongue I'm not
sure so your career it's so vast that
there's no way to cover at all just over
ten banks let me just hit you with some
lucy's while you choke down the Hellfire
fear this which music video is more fun
to shoot Bob Dylan's when the deal goes
down or Justin Timberlake's what goes
around comes around I probably see the
Bob Dylan video cuz my best were my
really good best friend shot it and so
I'd say that I find better outside of
your Marvel work
what's the Scarlett Johansson film that
you think has the most intense cult
following um I would probably say lost
in translation or oddly Lucy I've had
like so many random different types of
people from all walks of life tell me
that they have loved that movie
including Meryl Streep at the Oscars and
I was like what like she turned on she
was like oh my god it's you I was like
hi it's you and she was like I you know
what movie I absolutely loved of yours
and I was like why did she was like Lucy
I was like oh really she's like I love
that moment thought okay all right not
the one I would have you know I don't
know you never know you never know I
still don't know what that movies about
but she does which Scarlett Johansson
movie is more underrated home alone
three or eight legged freaks hey like it
breaks yeah oh that little bites
oh it just it still packed a punch well
you know what you've handled the
haymaker you've handled the Roundhouse
it's just one more round to go
oh the last time that's right because
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to let me just
smell it
yeah it smells good thank you
I actually make this one yeah I've seen
the show before alright cuz the way you
did it is cray and then you're gonna
dippity-do yep alright cheers Cheers
scarlet alright
my shopping I'm just staying on top of
it too you know I don't have the rice I
don't have the white bread I don't have
a beer I'll take it it I feel like else
it may be you know duals my it's an
O'Doul's
all right Scarlett Johansson here we are
at the top of spice Mountain it's season
82 at the tip-top of spice Mountain
yodel and from the summit and you know
what it's the last wing here of season
eight and when you're doing Avengers
every interview it's like tiptoeing
through a minefield it's like walking on
a tightrope the fans they're so rabid
they need those conspiracy theories they
need those spoilers and while you're
distracted by the hot sauce we're gonna
take our shot but we're gonna play fair
okay do not answer any of these
questions got it you know we're just
gonna look at your face and decide
whether you're giving us a tell or if
you're just reacting to hot sauce and
we'll be able to know because this is
always a truth serum okay Captain
America will die goose the cat will
ultimately be the key to saving
everybody Thanos gets tricked into the
quantum realm by ant-man and then the
Avengers beat him up and leave him there
[Music]
Loki isn't dead because he stabbed
Thanos with his left hand instead of his
right so it's obvious that we're just
seeing a projection and then finally if
Thanos isn't bad he's just under the
evil spell of the mind stone are you
honestly do not know what those last
three things you said were because my
mouth is on just it it's like just full
of fire well you know what I think that
you're under the spell of the hot sauce
stone but it doesn't matter
scarlet because you just went ten
chicken wings up ten chicken wings down
oh my god now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
like right at this very moment I'm
feeling pretty vulnerable right now I'm
not gonna lie here on the Avengers end
game press tour and I've already I
already feel pretty broken down and I'm
not gonna lie this may be the straw that
broke the camel's back so go see The
Avengers end game and yeah and that's
that that's their my final moment so you
just witnessed in here that my hey
what's going on hot ones fans this is
Sean Evans checking in from the Museum
of curiosities with a very exciting
sauce update if you have not subscribed
to the hot ones monthly subscription box
April is the month to do it why well
first off limited edition sticker but
second because this box is going to have
three hot sauces that have never before
been tasted never been released never
before seen until this month they're all
made by hot sauce makers that have
previously been featured on hot ones
that's right
three bottles of hot sauce no one's ever
seen before no one's ever tasted before
no one's ever touched until you reach
into that box and pull it out and put it
on your Caesar chicken wrap for the very
first time that's April subscription box
three bottles thirty bucks
plus a limited edition sticker who's
looking out for you
us